the former chief of the defence staff
general sir david richards
who is in uh i think it's hampshire this
evening thanks for being with us well we
spoke a week or two ago you said all was
not lost in afghanistan do you think it
is now
yeah i mean i i felt it was gonna be
lost but uh not in the time frame uh
even i um and i've seen a bit uh are
pretty stunned by the speed of the
taliban advance
but as soon as president biden took that
decision uh the morale uh the bottom of
you like went out of the afghan armed
forces and it was inevitable and that's
what's happened that's why they haven't
for they've helped no
they they didn't have their friends and
legit logistic and commanding control
experts let alone the air support they
needed uh and i'm afraid they packed up
and that's what soldiers will do where
are we now without a doubt we have to
come to terms with the fact that the
taliban has won
it's a very sorry day because it wasn't
necessary
but they won uh and that we now need to
do some sort of deal with them and exert
whatever leverage we can over their
condo
right well the taliban is one you say i
mean that must be
heartbreaking for you you led men there
you saw blood spilt there
do you feel angry about
the way it's happened
i do actually and i think most of us do
uh because it was unnecessary um and
it's quite clear that western
governments have been caught completely
by surprise i just heard the prime
minister uh i was very disappointed by
most of what he said but the fact is uh
they've completely outpaced us the
taliban
the the non-combatant evacuation
operation
um that is taking place today is taking
place
under the taliban that is not what was
intended and it's uh a huge you know
commentary on the fact that they have
outpaced us and and caught us out uh it
wasn't intended it wasn't necessary and
we could have sustained the operation
that we've had in place for a few years
now for many years more there was no
political pressure on president biden as
i understand it from my american friends
and there's certainly no political
pressure here
i know the british government were
disappointed in the americans decision
but i do feel nato led if necessary by
britain and france could have done a lot
more quickly to stabilize the situation
and prevent this from happening the fact
they didn't is a of us
it's a sad testament of nato's real
strength without american underpinning
and of our really our lack of
international diplomatic clout and you
say you heard the prime minister
speaking there what disappointed you
about what he said and what what could
he have should he have done more
well the first thing i must pick him up
on is yes he's right for 20 years we
have not had a terrorist attack from
afghanistan planned or executed
but
what now
there's a whole load of ungoverned space
i want to hear along with many many
others not just ex-military or serving
military what the plan is to deal with
that uh the taliban in some cases
uh will be uh amenable they're you know
they've become much more savvy over the
last 20 years but the fact is there's a
lot of unpleasant people they've teamed
up with over the years and we know are
mingled with them at the moment that
they will find very difficult to control
they will start to work now on planning
um reprisals against the west i fear it
will draw in uh other similarly minded
people it will uh revitalize um
radicalize
radical groups in various other parts of
the region uh and all together
militant islam
if that's the right term is now on the
rise again um now that is a ga strategic
failure of huge proportions uh china and
russia uh will and i i naided the prime
minister saying that we've got to remain
as one on this
his worry i'm sure is that russia and
china will do independent deals with the
new taliban government and that may
effectively will fill the vacuum that we
were very firmly in charge of
and just briefly 20 seconds left do you
see a day when nato forces will be back
in afghanistan
i think if um
terrorist groups reform
uh in the way i fear could happen but
we've got to exert some leverage now
over the taliban i must say that and
deal with them then it's inevitable that
in one way or another nato will have to
be back in there just to protect
ourselves okay uh general richards
appreciate your time thank you